Ein italienisches forschungsteam hat einen rund 20 kilometer breiten see unter dem eis des mars süd
aufgespürt mit flüssigem wasser weil könnte es dort leben geben wie genau diese
spektakuläre entwicklung gelangen um ob es auch schon konkrete hinweise auf außerirdisches leben gibt das alles jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Die planeten mars saturn und jupiter gelten alle schon seit längerer zeit als äußerst aussichtsreiche orte in unserem sonnensystem
auf denen bzw deren monden
außerirdisches leben vermutet wird und die fahndung läuft auf hochtouren wir hatten darüber berichtet erst vor kurzem hatte der mars rover curiosity eine
spannende entdeckung in dem jahr milliarden altem gestein des mars gemacht
organischer materie nämlich also sehr einfache kohlenstoffverbindungen
die hinweise auf eine lebensfreundliche zeit auf dem roten planeten geben möglicherweise hat es dort also mal von
mikroben nur so gewimmelt zudem hatte der nasa war auch eine
methankonzentration in der mars luft festgestellt die stark schwankt auf der erde entsteht methan durch
biologische prozesse beispielsweise wenn rinder ihre nahrung verdauen jetzt gibt es eine weitere
wirklich spektakuläre entdeckung auf dem mars ein forschungsteam aus bologna
hat gleich einen ganzen see aus flüssigem wasser entdeckt und zwar rund
1,5 kilometer unter dem eis das master puls die iraner daten vom mars express der europäischen
raumfahrtagentur esa zeigen dies und zwar in der südpolregion des roten planeten
planung ausstrahle die daten zeigen in dieser akte grenzen region dieselben signaturen wie sehen unter dem eis in polar regionen der erde
sie zeigen und den unterirdischen seen wie beispielsweise dem lake willens in der antarktis
wimmelt es nur so von mikroben bedeutet das etwa dass die existenz von leben auch in diesem gletschersee des mars eine klare sache ist
flüssiges wasser ist schließlich die
grundvoraussetzung für leben wie wir es kennen die fachwelt ist sich weiterhin nicht sicher denn darauf geben die radar beobachtungen keine direkten hinweise
an der südpolregion des roten planeten ist es deutlich kälter als in den unterirdischen seen der erde bei minus
68 grad celsius soll die temperatur des jetzt entdeckten maß sees liegen
dass das wasser flüssig ist liegt nach vermutung des forschungsteams an einem hohen salzgehalt natrium magnesium und kalium
salze die sowieso häufig auf dem mars anzutreffen sind könnten den gefrierpunkt des sees deutlich herabgesetzt haben eine derart hohe
salzkonzentration mache es für mögliches leben in dem maß wasser nicht gerade einfach doch ein
ausschlusskriterium ist dies nach ansicht des forschungsteams nicht denn auch auf der erde gibt es mikroorganismen
die mit einer hohen
salzkonzentration zurechtkommen ein weiterer unterschied
zu dem irdischen see der antarktis ist übrigens dass der leg willens in der antarktis kein
abgeschlossenes ökosystem ist denn ein unterirdischer fluss sorgt dafür dass das wasser regelmäßig
ausgetauscht wird jedenfalls sei mit dieser entdeckung jetzt eine jahrelange diskussion beendet so das fazit der amerikanischen gesellschaft zur förderung der wissenschaften
die auch die aktuelle studie der italienischen
forscherinnen und forscher in ihrem fachblatts science veröffentlicht hat denn bisher hatte man auf dem markt nur winzige spuren von flüssigem wasser aufspüren können beispielsweise
hatten sich auf dem nas lande modul phoenix
wassertropfen niedergeschlagen zudem hatte man auch strukturen an den polkappen entdeckt die von eis stammen könnten ein weiteres indiz
in der äußerst dünnen luft des mars befindet sich auch ein geringer anteil an wasserdampf ja das war es aber auch
bisher an hinweisen dennoch hatten einige
forschungsteam schon seit rund 30 jahren spekuliert dass unter den polkappen als flüssiges wasser existieren
könnte vergleichbar mit den unterirdischen seen auf der erde gelegen in grönland und der antarktis
hundertprozentig sicher waren sich die forschungsteams allerdings bislang nur dass es mal vor milliarden jahren wasser gegeben
haben muss denn darauf weisen ausgetrocknete sedimente und flussläufe hin und so wurde in den letzten jahren eigentlich
diskutiert gibt es auf dem mars flüssiges wasser oder nicht hatte vielleicht sogar mal ein ganzer ozean den mars vor langer zeit
bedeckt bislang waren das alles spekulationen die durch diese entdeckung jetzt wissenschaftliches fundament bekommen haben
und das forschungsteam ist sich ziemlich sicher dass
dieser eine unterirdische sie kein einzelfall auf dem mars ist denn bisher ist wohl nur ein kleiner teil der südpol kappe untersucht worden
deswegen sei es durchaus wahrscheinlich dass
unterirdisches flüssiges wasser auch an anderer stelle vorkommen ich denke dass er der entdeckung von leben im weltall
wirklich immer näher kommen ich bin wirklich
extrem gespannt wenn ihr kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp darum geht ihr die na ja
etwas unzuverlässige abo boxee auf youtube und ihr verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich
von jedem upload und zwar noch vor allen andern täglich und garantieren einfach hier draufklicken
und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber
nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken außerirdisches leben auf dem mars neue indizien ja es gibt immer mehr hinweise
also bis dann
bleibt dran